[موسيقى]
عن المراه الفلسطينيه نتحدث الليله شقيقه
الرجال ورفيقه النضال يصيبها ما يصيبهم من
قهر واسر ورغم مسؤولياتها الجسام في انجاب
الثوار والاحرار ورعايه جمعها حتى ينضج
ويقوى لا تنسى حظها من النضال تشبثا
بالارض وزودا عن العبد فتواجه اما الشهاده
او الاسر فمنذ عام
1967 تعرضت نحو 17 الف فلسطينيه للاعتقال
والاسر تستخدم قوات الاحتلال ذلك كاداه
للضغط على ذويهن او عقابا على نشاطهن
السياسي او الطلابي او حتى لمجرد الاشتباه
يقتدن من بيوتهم او من نقاط التفتيش او
حتى خلال زياره ابنائهن في السجون ليعشن
تجربه مريره قاسيه قد تستمر سنوات يواجهن
فيها ظروفا وانتهاكات تتنافى مع ابسط
مبادئ حقوق الانسان والقوانين الدوليه
اليوم تت الارقام لكن المؤكد ان نحو 30
اسيره فلسطينيه على الاقل محتجزات في
السجون الاسرائيليه بينهن قاصرات وامهات
وحتى جريحات ومريضات يعانين الاهمال الطبي
مما يزيد معاناتهم نذكر منهن على سبيل
المثال للحصر فدوى حماده واماني الحشيم
ختام السعافين شذى عوده
الاسيره ام الاسرى واسراء جعابيص وغيرهم
ولكل واحده منهن قصه معاناه ونضال في
مواجهه السجن والسجان وقصه صمود في وجه
الاحتلال اما في قصتنا الليله الاسيرات
الفلسطينيات فقد التقينا معتصم ابن اسراء
جعابيص التي اعتقلت وعوقبت بالسجن احد عشر
عاما اثر النشوب حريق في سيارتها قرب حاجز
عسكري وكل ما يتمناه معتصم ان يعود يوما
من المدرسه ليجد امه في انتظاره التقينا
ايضا الاسيرات المحررات خالد جرار النائبه
في المجلس التشريعي الفلسطيني القياديه في
الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين وقد كابدت
الاعتقال والاثر عده مرات وفي اخر اعتقال
لها فقدت ابنتها
كما روت لنا شذى حسون وفاطمه الزق ونسرين
ابو كميل قصص الانتهاكات التي تتعرض لها
المراه الفلسطينيه عند الاعتقال والتعذيب
خلال التحقيقات ومعاناتها من الاهمال
الطبي والتضييق وحتى الحرمان من الزياره
العائليه خلال سنوات الاسر اما بقيه هذه
القصه فنستكمل ابعادها مع سحر فرانسيس
مديره مؤسسه الضمير لرعايه الاسير وحقوق
الانسان وسوسن بكير والده الاسيره مرح
بكير واحمد جرادات زوج الاسيره عطاف
جرادات نسال ضيوفنا عن مقاومه المراه
الفلسطينيه للاحتلال سواء داخل السجون او
حتى خارجها وعن تاثير هذه المعاناه معاناه
الاسر على العائلات الفلسطينيه خصوصا
الاطفال وكذا التحركات لانهاء سياسات
الاعتقال الاداري والعزل الانفرادي
للاسيرات وتحريرهم لكن لنشاهد القصه بدءا
وبعدها الحوار
كان شعوري كثير ملخبط شعور بالصدمه شعور
بانه انا رايحه للمجهول انا مش عارفه وين
رايحه
يعني انا بقولا دايما يعني مش بس هم بدهم
نحكي هم كمان بدهم مشينا نتنفس يعني حتى
الاكسجين بحاولوا انهم يمنعوا
بتضل اضطهاد ضد الاحتلال
احتلال ما بشبه ما بشبعوا حتى لو حركها لا
ما بشبعوا هذا الشيء انت بتعذبيني وانا
رايحه اولد مش عارفه لسه ساعتي الولاد ايش
بده يكون ايش منتظرني منهم فهذا عمليه
تعذيب تعذيب يعني او قتل غير مباشر
[موسيقى]
وفقا لتقرير صادر عن جمعيه نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني في السابع من مارس لعام 2022 ان
عدد الاسيرات لدى الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 32
اسيرا من بينهن 11 اسيره من الامهات وست
جريحات وطفله واحده وثلاثه يخضعن للاعتقال
الاداري
المقطع الجيش الاحتلال يعني البيت خلونا
انه نقعد انا وماما واختي هون
واخذوا بابا على باب البيت بلحظه الحكي
فيها ضابط المخابرات لبابا انه خليه تجهز
حالها الاعتقاري الليله لها انا كنت بزبط
هون يعني وسمعت الكلمه وانا هون
بعدها جا والدي يعني
ووقفنا هون وحكى لي انه شذى جهزي حالك
الليله الاعتقال لك وما تخافي يعني
البسي جاكيتك
الله معك يا شباب
هو بالاعتقالي الاداري ما بيكون في رائحه
اتهام ما بيكون في اي تهمه بكون فقط ملف
سري المحامي قصدي النيابه والقاضي اللي
بيكونوا بيعرفوا شو فيه ولكن لا انا ولا
محاميه بنكون نعرف شوفي بالملف
بحسب مؤسسه الضمير لرعايه الاسير وحقوق
الانسان في الاعتقال الاداري يمكن تجديد
امر الاعتقال مرات غير محدوده حيث يتم
استصدار امر اعتقال اداري لفتره اقصاها
سته شهور قابله للتجديد
[موسيقى]
من عائلتك من الناس كثير المساله صعبه
يعني
فما في اشي اسمه انه احنا بنتعود على
الاعتقاله كل مره بتكون يمكن اصعب
من اللي قبلها لانه اول شيء احنا بنلاحظ
انه في تطور كتير في اساليب كيف انهم
يحاولوا
يعزلوكي بشكل كامل عن العالم
كنت معديه من معبر ايرز في هذا اليوم كان
في صوت من مكبرات
الصوت بنادي علي فاطمه تقدمي افرغ الحقيبه
طبعا انا معي شنطه بس فقط شنطه كتفي وفيها
الموبايل وفيها فلوس وفيها كتيبات دينيه
واغراضي فرغت الحقيبه وانا اثناء مروري من
العماره الامن استشعرت انه انا في عمليه
اعتقال
قعدت لفتره لاني تاقلمت اني انا بسجن كنت
كل ما انزل محكمه قعدت فتره انزل كل
بالاسبوع مرتين محاكم في بير السبع هقول
اليوم مروحه
[موسيقى]
الاسيره الانثى يعني هي لديها اصلا كل
القوانين العالميه ضمنت لها تمييز ايجابي
يلبي احتياجاتها الخاصه ولكن اسرائيل طبعا
تتنكر لكل نص جاء على ذكره قانون دولي او
اتفاقيه دوليه او اي نص
يعني يحترم
حقوق الاسيرات وتحديد ما يتعلق بخصوصيتهن
سابقا كانت تتواجد الاسيرات الفلسطينيه
داخل سجنها شارون في شمال اسرائيل مع
تزايد اعدادهن تم نقلهن جميعا الى سجن
الدامون في حيفا وبعدها تحول سجنها شارون
الى مركز توقيف او معمار احتجاز منه يتم
نقل الاسيرات الى المحاكم او سجن الدامون
في ما يسمى بالمعبار اللي بفتقد لا ادنى
شروط الانسانيه بمعنى انه فقط فرشه
بلاستيك بطانيه متعبه تنقلك في رحله
الى 12 ساعه تقريبا اللي هي يعني رحله
صعبه جدا في البوسطه اللي هي ظروف النقل
فيها كتير صعبه بنكون مربطين ايدينا
واجرينا
سجن الدامون وهو سجن كان اصلا مخزنا للتبغ
يعني لم يبنى كسجن ثم ان لجنتين
اسرائيليتين في فترتين مختلفتين اقرتا بان
هذا السجن لا يصلح للحياه الادميه وقامت
اسرائيل باغلاقه في الانتفاضات عادت
اسرائيل وافتتحته لحاجتها لاماكن احتجاز
[موسيقى]
قسم الاسيرات يكون في داخل سجن يعني في
الاصل للسجناء الجنائيين اليهود وغير
اليهود على قضاء الجنائيه وليست قضايا
امنيه او سياسيه يكون في داخل هذا السجن
قسم
خاص بالاسيرات
الامنيات الفلسطينيات طبعا وبالتالي سياسه
التعامل مع السجناء
الجنائيين
الجانب السلبي منها يطبق على الاسيرات
والجانب الايجابي بالتاكيد لا تطبقه اداره
السجون على
الاسيرات في موضوع الزيارات موضوع
الكانتين على سبيل المثال او التعليم وكل
القضايا يعني المسموحه في السجون الجنائيه
يحرم منها الاسيرات في داخل السجون
[موسيقى]
من هناك اللي هو اللي بتيجي اداره السجن
لحتى تعد الاسيرات ولازم نصحى عليه ونوقف
نلبس اواعي الصلاه لانهم بدخلوا ضباط
الاعداد وسجانين
بعدها تقريبا تستمر عمليه العدد نصف ساعه
ليخلصوا كل الغرف في القسم وبيطلعوا على
الساعه سبعه كانوا يفتحوا لنا ساعه رياضه
لنخرج يعني على ساعه
ونمارس الرياضه طبعا شو هي الرياضه اللي
بيقدروا الاسيرات يمارسوها اللي هي فقط
المشي لانه بساحه الفورا في كاميرات فما
بيقدروا الاسيرات خصوصا المحجبات انهم
مثلا يعملوا اي حركات رياضيه تانيه او انه
ما في عنا اصلا معدات الرياضه اللي ممكن
نستخدمها لنعمل رياضه في الساعه سته بندخل
طبعا خلص
بتسكر القسم علينا سته بالشتاء و سته ونص
بالصيف بردو بيجوا بيعدونا وبعدها خلاص
انت بضل مسكر
[موسيقى]
ان اعتقال الاسيرات في سجن الدامون يتعرض
بشكل مباشر مع نص الماده 49 من اتفاقيه
جنيفر رابعه التي تحضر على القوه المحتله
نقل الاشخاص المحميين وخاصه المحتجزين من
الارض المحتله
تنفذ اداره السجون الاحتلال بحق الاسيرات
سلسله من الاجراءات التنكيليه مثل التعذيب
اثناء التحقيق والاهمال الطبي وعدم
استخدام الهواتف العموميه والحرمان من
زياره المحامي او العائله وحرمان الاسيرات
الامهات من الزيارات المفتوحه واحتضان
ابنائهم
انا الي 13 سنه محرره لكني
يعني اعصابي تعبانه وبتعالج على طول باخذ
مغذيات وابر
[موسيقى]
سجن سباب لعده امران يعني صار معي ضغط
وسكري
صار معي ربو من رطوبه الغرف عملت عده
عمليات داخل السجن اول عمليه عملتها هي
استئصال كتله بصدري سرطانيه الحمد لله انه
طلعت حميد يعني وبعدين وقعت في ثلاثين
واحد
2018 وقعت وكسرت ايدي وجبصوا لي اياها
بطريقه خاطئه لليوم بعاني منها بعمل لسه
في عمليتين يعني
[موسيقى]
معنوياتك اوك لانه كل الدنيا كل الدنيا
قاعده في كتير فراغات كانت امي كانت
الوالده معبيتها سواء في البيت او في
حياتنا الشخصيه او حتى في حياتنا المهنيه
الزياره هي الوسيله الوحيده اللي طبعا اول
ما اعتقل بدنا شي شهرين ثلاثه عبين ما
يطلع لاهل تصريح الزياره لا يسمح لالهم
بالزياره فانا عمليا فقط ثلاث مرات او
اربع مرات خلال السنتين
قدرت انه اشوف اهلي في الزياره عاد ممنوع
يسلموا بس يومها صار جدل بين المحاميه
وبين القاضي وبين بتاع الهاد ابصر شو
بحكوا كذا بقول لها انا هلا بخليهم يسلموا
عليها فالكل انصدم اجوا سلموا علي
يلا ارجعي لوراء تفضل
[موسيقى]
يلا صبايا
عشاني الام المخاض
واخذوني بصوره مش انسانيه
كلبشات وحديد وفرجليه وايديا بل السجانه
كانت تعص الازاجيم
اشرف يوسف على الحياه وابصر النور وكان
بيبكي حطوه لحظات يعني ثواني على صدري
وانا اترجاهم خلوه انا انا مسكته هيك وانا
بحكي معه وانا هيني يا ماما يا حبيبي يا
ماما وانت عندي وانا معاك
ودموعي نزلت يعني فرحه وسعاده وحنان وكنت
استشعر بمعيه ربي سبحانه وتعالى ثم اخذوا
مني تركوني
بدون ما ينهوا عمليه الولاده بس طلعوا
الجنين
وتركوني كلبشونه
[موسيقى]
المره المتزوجه صحيح غير عن البنت اللي
عزباء وهيك كانت صعبه بالاخص اني انا سيبت
ابني احمد ثمان شهور يعني كان يجي كل ما
يمرق يوم اقول له هايبر هيك صار هيك
فكانوا يعني بعد تقريبا سبع شهور ثمان
شهور لاني سمعتهم على الايداع فكانوا
يبعتوا لي الاخبار مع المحامي انه بلش
يخطي بلش نطق ماما للوقوف عند رد مصلحه
السجون على بعض الانتهاكات التي تؤكدها
الاسيرات توجهنا لهم بطلب اجراء مقابله
فلم يسمحوا بذلك وتمت الاجابه على اسئلتنا
عبر البريد الالكتروني
قال لاوامر مصلحه الس
[موسيقى]
جون زيارات عائليه للاقارب من الدرجه
الاولى كل شهرين او اكثر كلما امكن ذلك
بخصوص المكالمات الهاتفيه لا يحق للسجينات
المصنفات على انهن السجينات امنيات اجراء
مكالمات هاتفيه الا في حاله وجود عدد من
الاستثناءات
[موسيقى]
الغرف في الجناح واسعه وهناك اماكن عامه
للتعلم والطهي والتخزين بالنسبه لوسائل
التدفئه والتبريد فهي حسب المواسم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جميع السجينات تخضعن لمتابعه طبيه منتظمه
ويتلقين العلاج الذي يتناسب مع حالتهن
الطبيه لا يمكن لدائره السجون ان تشير
بشكل فردي الى الحاله الطبيه الخاصه
بسجينه معينه او باخرى وذلك بسبب السريه
الطبيه
في الحادي عشر من اكتوبر لعام 2015 تعرضت
المقدسيه اسراء الجعابيص لحادث عربي نشب
عنه حريق داخل سيارتها وبسبب القرب من احد
الحواجز اصر الاحتلال على انها كانت تريد
تنفيذ عمليه تفجيريه وهي من الاسيرات
الامهات داخل سجن الدامون
بعدين طلعت منها تنهيده كبيره فاحنا حكينا
لها انه مالك انه في اشي فبتحكي لا بس عم
بتخيل انه انا لما اطلع ابني معتصم راح
يكون طالع له شوارب وطالع له لحيه وانا مش
رح اقدر احسس عليه وجهه ناعم راح يبطل
الطفل اللي انا تركته
اليوم مش زي ايام زمان
اليوم انه ارجع اروح من المدرسه اجي على
قيمه بالدار
[موسيقى]
تم حرق اسراء 70% من جازتها اسراء عندها
موهبه كانت قبل ما تعتقل اسراء كانت تشتغل
مهرج
تتبرع بالدار الايتام الروضات الاطفال
اسراء بتمسك القلم هون وهوايتها الرسم
فبتعلم الاسيرات الرسم داخل القصر كمان
حتى كمان كانت ترسم على الكروت للبنات
لاعياد الميلاد رسم اسراء هذا
ترسم اكثر من هذا الاشي كمان اسراء
اسرائيل
باعتبار قمعي قهري والاعتبار مادي هي تعلم
انها حاجه اسراء الى عمليات يعني نقلها
الى مستشفيات وان يكون لديها حراسات ودفعت
تكاليف ونفقات المستشفيات فلذلك يتركوا
الاسير او الاسير وهنا نتحدث عن الاسراء
في معاناه شديده الى ان تخرج من السجن
وقد يكون يعني اجراء العمليه في وقتها
يعني افضل بكثير قد لا يكون ممكن اجراء
العمليات الممكنه اليوم بعد خمس او ست
سنوات
يتضمن الجمهور الفلسطيني مع الاسيرات من
خلال اطلاق حملات الكترونيه واعتصامات
ومظاهرات ميدانيه لا سيما في اواخر 2021
بعدما حاول الاحتلال قمعهن بالقوه لفرض
مزيد من السيطره والرقابه عليهم
[موسيقى]
او حياه ما بعد الاسر كانت سهله الا انه
انا قدرت اتجاوزها بفضل يعني بفضل اهلي
اولا بفضل المجتمع الجامعه وصاحباته
وصديقاتي حاليا عم بشتغل مرشده للاطفال من
سن يعني صف ثالث في مدرسه ممكن هذا المجال
البلاقي حالي فيه يعني مجال
انه اترك اثر في اي حدا والحمد لله يعني
هو بالنهايه كان حلم والحمد لله انه هو
تحقق وان حاليا عم بشتغل فيه
[موسيقى]
هذا يوسف الطقم
اللي تحررت فيه
[موسيقى]
يوم ما طلعنا من السجن انا واياك
طلعت فيه
كنت ايش
زي الامير كان بابا يزورني في السجن لا
بابا ما شافك ولا زارك غير عن طريق الصور
انت كنت تتعلق فيه يعني حاطه لك صوره جنب
السرير احكي لك وين بابا يا يوسف تحكي لي
تقشرنا عليه
[موسيقى]
طبعا يعني هي اصعب المحطات بتكون لما حدا
بيفقد حدا
عزيز عليه وهو في داخل الاسر في اعتقالي
انا 2017 فقدت الوالد توفى يعني وانا
بالسجن وفي اعتقال الاخير قبل اطلاق سراحي
بشهرين تقريبا نص فقدت بنتي
انه كان من اصعب الاشياء اللي
واجهتها
عشان هيك المباشره توجهت
انه لقبرها احاول
[موسيقى]
تحيه للمراه الفلسطينيه الباسقه كالنخله
في صمودها امام كل محاولات النيل منها
وانا لهم ذلك نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
وبضيوفنا ايضا الكرام معنى من رام الله
سحر فرنسيس مديره مؤسسه الضمير لرعايه
الاسير وحقوق الانسان ومن القدس الشرقيه
سوسن بكير والده الاسيره مرحبا
مدينه جنين احمد جرادات وهو زوج الاسيره
عطاف جرادات اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لعلنا
نبدا معك سيده سحر ونتساءل حقيقه لاننا
خلال اعداد هذه الحلقه
يعني واجهتنا معضله الارقام هي تختلف بين
فتره واخرى وحسب المصادر ايضا هل تحتكمون
على ارقام رسميه لاعداد الاسيرات في سجون
الاحتلال
مساء الخير طبعا حاليا هناك
احدى وثلاثون اسيره فلسطينيه تخضع في سجون
الاحتلال
وثلاثه عشر منهم هم محكومات منهم ثمان
اسيرات احكامهم تتجاوز العشر سنوات واربعه
عشر اسيره تنتظر محاكمتها وهناك اسيرتين
رهن الاعتقال الاداري واسيرتين اما
بالتوقيف لم تقدم لهم لوائح اتهام او
يخضعن للتحقيق في مراكز التحقيق طبعا ماذا
عن الاسرى سيده سحر طبعا لا نريد
استثنائهم لكن هذه الحلقه مخصصه للمراه
وقد خصصنا طبعا حلقات اخرى للاسرى
الفلسطينيين مع اخر الارقام التي تحتكمون
اليها بخصوصهم
طبعا حاليا هناك
4900 تاثير فلسطيني في داخل سجون الاحتلال
منهم 160 اسير طفل ما دون سن 18 عام
وحوالي 1000 معتقل اداري بدون محاكمه او
تهمه طبعا
الاحتلال يعني لم يستثني لا حرائر فلسطين
ولا اطفالها ولا رجالها ولعله الثمن الذي
يدفع الحريه نعود اليك طبعا سيده سحر لكن
اود ان اسمع
للجانب الاخر لعائلات التي تعاني هي
بدورها ايضا مثل ما تعاني الاسيرات لعلنا
نبدا مع ضيفتنا الكريمه سيده سوسن البكير
وهي والده مرح نتساءل حقيقه عن مرح هل لها
من اسمها نصيب هي التي تبلغ اليوم 24 عاما
اعتقلت وعمرها 16 عاما في طريق عودتها من
المدرسه اتهمت بعمليه طعن
واخترق جسدها الغد انذاك 14 رصاصه ماذا
فعلت السنين بمرح سنين الاسر
مساء الخير للجميع مرح طفله وما زالت اصلا
طفله صحيح عمرها صار 24 سنه لكن ما رح
دخلته عمرها 16 سنه كل التفاصيل اللي
حكوها الاسيرات خلال التقرير مرح عانت
منها مع انها طفله وكانت بحاجه تكون
موجوده مع اهلها مع اخوتها بحاجه انه
نائتني فيها وهي مصابه ب 14 رصاصه في
ايدها بس للاسف الاحتلال ما بميز بين
اسيره بين اعشاب بين طفل
ما راح هي مرح الكل بشهد بتحكه مرح اللي
دائما دائما معبيه القسم هذا دليل انه
مهما يحاولوا يعني يهزموه عزيمه الاسيرات
او الاسرى ولكن عازمتهم دائما بتكون اقوى
يعني اسالك كام يعني كل ام يعني حتما لا
تتمنى ان ترى ايا من فيدتك بدها وراء
السجون لكن تجربه الاسر لقضيه مثل قضيه
فلسطين كيف ترينها هل ترينها شرفا ام ان
كلمه الامهات في نهايه الامر كنت تتمنين
فعلا ان تكبر فرح يعني في في البيت بين
اخوتها وتحت نظرك يعني تتمتع بكل حنانك
سنه ونص
طبعا وراء كل فلسطينيه قصه وقصص تحول
السيد احمد جرادات وورائه ليست قصه واحده
عده قصص انت زوج الاسيره عطاف جرادات
الاسيره ام الاسرى ايضا انت والد الاسرى
عمر وغيث ومنتصر كيف تعيش هذه التجربه
اجمالا
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
ويعطيكم العافيه على جهودكم يعني انا اعرف
عن نفسي الاستاذ احمد ياسين جرادات ابو
المنتصر بالله والد الاسرى الثلاثه
المنتصر بالله وحزب الله عمر و غيث الله
وزوج الاسير المناضله المجاهده البطله
اطاف جرادات ام المنتصر نحن نعيش يعني
ظروف قاسيه وصعبه جدا جدا نحن مشتتين عندي
طفلان طفله يعني اسرت امها واخوتها
الثلاثه وهي كانت عمرها 14 سنه
يعني وابن المقدام راغب كان عمره 15 سنه
وكان مصاب واجره معاقة مشلوله وعلى يعني
لا يكوى على الحركه عندما اعتقلت امه
واسرت امه والان نحن مشتتون من يومها الى
الان
يعني كل واحد منا انا اتنقل بين البيوت
المهدومه عند بنتي منطقه بعيده
المقدام راغب في بيت وهنادي في بيت لا
نلتقي قليلا ولا في يعني لا في اي مناسبه
نفتقد نفتقد يعني اما المنتصر المراه التي
لم يعني يكون هناك مثيل لها في الكرم
والباع الطويل والنشاط والجد والاجتهاد
لصاحبه اللمات الكريمه لاولادها
وبناتها واحفادها يعني زوجتي هي اكبر
الاسيرات عمرها 52 سنه وعندها 21 حفيد
وتسع اولاد سته من الذكور وثلاثه من
البنات
ويعني كل المصائب والابتلاءات التي نزلت
بنا لو نزلت على جبال نزلت على جبال هدتها
لكننا محتسبون صابرون
وكل ذلك يهون في سبيل الله وفي سبيل
فلسطين والقدس والاقصى الله اسرها واسرها
واسر جميع ابطال وبطلات فلسطين سيد احمد
يعني ماذا لو حددت المشاهد الكريم وضعته
في صوره اعتقال زوجتك الكريمه سيده عطاف
هل الامر علاقه بابنائك الاسرى وهم ثلاثه
كما ذكرت
يعني هي القصه انه احنا تفاجانا انا
كاوالد والاقارب يعني ليله اعتقال ابنائي
كانت فيها هجمه مسعوره شرسه في القنابل
مئات الاليات العسكريه وفرق ضباط تحقيق
يعني في لمحات في لمح البصر اخذوا اولادي
على الشوارع امامنا وصاروا يحققوا معهم
تحقيق ميداني تفاجانا كثيرا وقعدوا حوالي
اربع ساعات والتحقيق يعني الكلاب يعني
اخرجت السلاح كشفت السلاح
ورويدا رويدا علمنا من بعض الضباط وهو
عربي ان اولادي متورطين وقتل وقاموا
بعمليه حومش
بعد ثاني يوم ثاني يوم صباحا او بعد ساعات
جاءت
طواقم التلفزه ومنها
التلفزيون الجزيره مشكورا وقدمنا على
الاعلام وزوجتي يعني قابلوها وحكت قعدت
اسبوع بعدهم ثاني بعد 16 ساعه اجوا نفس
الاشي على البيوت الساعه عشره بالليل في
السهره وبشكل نفسي عنيف وصاروا طلعونا من
البيوت صاروا يعني ياخذوا قياسات للبيوت
ثلاثه بيتي وبيت اسد الله وبيت غايه حزب
الله عمر
نفس الشيء صارت لقاءات مع الصحافي
والاعلام ومع التلفزه
مشت الامور بعد اسبوع بالضبط واذا يعني
نتفاجئ بالجيش يدخل احنا فرغنا البيوت
ثاني يوم فرغنا البيوت جميعها الى الجيران
والمساجد
كنا واضحه يعني
يتهمون غيث الله بقيام بعمليه حومش هو
وخاله الشيخ محمد جرادات وابن خالي محمود
جرادات ابو ساجد واشركوا يعني هم
اطاف يعني التاموها انها كانت تعلم تعلم
وان اقامه بتوزيع حلوى الاعتقال ووصل
الامر الى يعني للمدينين والمستوطنين
وطالبوا بقصف بيتي وتدمير على رؤوسنا وقتل
زوجه وبعد سبع ايام اعتقلوا زوجتي ويعني
اهلها
يعني لغرابتها دان يتحول للسيده سحر
فرنسيس مثل هذه القصص على اختلاف الروايات
وعلى اختلاف الظروف ربما تعيشها العديد من
عائلات الاسرى يعتقل الفلسطيني على الشبهه
على اقل من على توزيع الحلوى على عده
اشياء يصعب ربما للعقل البشري ان يصدقها
ويستوعبها لكن هذا حال الفلسطيني وهذا
ديدا الاحتلال والسؤال هنا ان القوانين
الدوليه اين القضاء اين ما يمكن ان يقدم
لهؤلاء لنصرتهم
لتقديمهم ربما لمحاكمات عادله ياخذون بها
حقهم في نهايه الامر
مع كل اسف دوله الاحتلال تقوم بانتهاك
القانون الدولي الانساني وقانون الدول
لحقوق الانسان بشكل منهجي وبشكل يومي
ومستمر بحق الاسرى والاسيرات على كافه
المستويات من بدايه اللحظه الاولى
للاعتقال
خلال التحقيق من التعذيب وسوء المعامله
وعدم توفير المحاكمه العادله ونقلهم بشكل
قصري الى سجون داخل دوله الاحتلال والكثير
من الجرائم التي ترتقي لتكون جرائم حرب
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه ولكن للاسف هناك صمت
وغياب للمسائله والمحاكمه لدوله الاحتلال
على هذه الجرائم وهذا ما يعطيها الضوء
الاخضر لمواصله والاستمرار في مثل هذه
الانتهاكات وبالتالي اعتقد المشكله في
تنفيذ وتطبيق القانون الدولي والقانون
الدولي لحقوق الانسان والقانون الدولي
الانساني على دوله الاحتلال الزام دوله
الاحتلال باحترام مسؤولياتها وفي غياب
عاده في النظام الدولي اذا ما دوله معينه
لم تحترم القانون الدولي يتم فرض عقوبات
الا مع دوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى الان
ومنذ عقود لا يتم فرض عقوبات بسبب هذه
شهاده الاسيره المحرره شذى حسون التي
تحدثت عن خضوعها لما يسمى بالاعتقال
الاداري نود ان تفصلي لنا قليلا في هذه
البدعه
القانونيه ان صح التعبير التي
اخترعتها اسرائيل ربما
لتضييق على الفلسطينيين واعتقالهم دونما
اي اتهامات او حتى محاكمات ولماذا تتزايد
اعداد هذا الاعتقال الاداري اكثر فاكثر
طبعا كما ذكرتي هي بدعه قانونيه
وريثتها دوله الاحتلال عن الانتداب
البريطاني انظمه الطوارئ البريطانيه للعام
45 وطورتها طبعا بما يتناسب وظروفها
واحتياجاتها وبالاساس هو اعتقال يستند
لملفات سريه لا تقدم بيانات ولا ادله ولا
يستطيع كما قالت شذى في التقرير للمحامي
ولا المعتقل معرفه ما هي اسباب الاعتقال
الحقيقيه وبالتالي كيف له ان يترافع
ويدافع عن اي معتقل وطبعا الاعتقال غير
محدد بفتره زمنيه مما يجعل الاعتقال نوع
من انواع وشكل من اشكال التعذيب النفسي
تستخدم دوله الاحتلال هذا الشكل من
الاعتقال لانه سهل بكل بساطه لا
ينجد ضروره
تقديم ادله للمحكمه فيكتفي بتقديم ملف سري
للقاضي وعاده يقوم يقوم القضاه بتثبيت
اوامر الاعتقال بناء على الملفات السريه
كما اصدرها القائد العسكري فهو شكل سهل
واداه سهله لاحتجاز المئات والالاف في
فتره وجيزه وقصيره ونحن نشهد حاليا ارتفاع
حاد لانه في العام المنصرم في مثل هذه
الايام كان العدد حوالي 450 معتقل اداري
حاليا العدد اكثر من الف اسير رهن
الاعتقال الاداري طبعا منهن اسيرتين في
الاعتقال الاداري وهذا يشير كلما كان هناك
ادعاء من قبل الاحتلال ارتفاع وتيره
المواجهه والنضال ضد الاحتلال يقوم
الاحتلال باحتجاز الفلسطينيين اكثر واكثر
رهن الاعتقال سيده سحر هناك ابعاد مختلفه
كما ذكرنا اضافه لاعتقال
السيدات والرجال هناك ايضا عمليات
الاعتقال التي تطل الاطفال اكثر من 160
طفل اسير والقاصرات ايضا
في هذه الحاله التي تتحدث عنها الليله
والسؤال حقيقه يعني ما مبررات اعتقال
الاطفال وفق وجهه نظر لاحتلال وكيف ينظر
اليها القانون الدولي وبماذا يمكن
المرافعه ايضا للدفاع عن هؤلاء الاطفال
طبعا حاليا هناك قاصره طفله في سجون
الاحتلال وكما ذكرت والده الاسيره مرح عن
حاله مرح بعض اصابتها بالرصاص في يدها
كانت هناك حجه بان مرح حاولت القيام
بعمليه طعن وتمت محاكمتها غالبيه الاطفال
يتم اعتقال اما من خلال وغالبا في ساعات
متاخره من منازلهم بحجه مشاركتهم في
مظاهرات او القاء حجاره ولكن ايضا هناك
حالات لاطفال تم اتهامهم بمحاولات القيام
بمحاولات طعن غالبا كما نذكر حاله الاسير
الطفل احمد مناصره في حينه الذي ما زال
يعاني ايضا من اثار الاعتقال وهو الان في
حبس انفرادي معاقب بالحبس الانفرادي طبعا
بعد قضاء اكثر من سبع سنوات هو بالغ الان
ولكن هناك اصرار
بعدم الافراج عنه بحجه انه هي مرتبطه
بالقيام بعمليه ارهابيه اريد ان اؤكد ان
دوله الاحتلال تطوع القانون المحلي ان كان
الاوامر العسكريه او القانون الجنائي في
داخل دوله الاحتلال لفرض العقوبات ومزيد
من سنوات السجن الفعلي بحق الاطفال ضاربه
بعرض الحائط اتفاقيه حقوق الطفل التي وقعت
عليها والتزمت بها دوله الاحتلال والتي
تطلب من الدول ان تكون العقوبه بالسجن
الفعلي هي الميلاد الاخير بمعنى انه حتى
لو خالف الطفل القانون يجب
التعامل مع الاطفال بشكل استثنائي التوجه
الى الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي والعلاج كله
نظري
الاحتلال ايضا تتحدث عن تمييز ايجابي كما
ذكر احد ضيوفنا تجاه السيدات لكننا لم نرى
ذلك في شهادات الاسيرات المحرره استمعنا
لقصه فاطمه التي جاءها المخاض وهي في
السجن وحكت يعني بطريقه
يعني تقشعره لها الابدان كيف وضعت ابنها
يوسف وراينا يوسف الذي كبر بعد ذلك وهم
يحكيان عن تجربه الاسرار وهذا يقودنا
للسؤال عن الانتهاكات كيف رصدتم هذه
الانتهاكات بحق الاسيرات الفلسطينيات في
السجون الاحتلال وما الذي يمكن فعله
طبعا الاسيرات يعانينا تماما كما الاسرى
الرجال داخل سجون الاحتلال من لحظه
الاعتقال الاولى هناك احيانا تفتيش عاري
مذل مهين حتى في المنزل
وهناك حالات صعبه جدا لممارسه التفتيش
العاري والاذلال وعمليه الضرب والتنكيل
والتهديد والصراخ والشتم والايذاء النفسي
والجسدي تستمر ايضا في سياره النقل من
المنزل الى مركز التحقيق في مراكز التحقيق
تتعرض الاسيرات ايضا للتعذيب لساعات تحقيق
طويله جدا للحرمان من النوم
للشبح على بوضعيات مختلفه مؤلمه لفترات
طويله
تكرار الاهانات هل توقفون كل ذلك هل هو
موثق سيده سحر
ربما تقديم ملفات وتجهيزها ربما للمستقبل
[موسيقى]
طبعا يجب ان انوه واشدد انه حتى ليست فقط
مؤسسه ضد الضمير هي المؤسسه الوحيده التي
تقوم بعمليات الرصد والتوثيق ولكن كافه
الملفات التي نقدمها كشكاوى للسلطات محليا
الجهات الاحتلال للتحقيق في هذه الجرائم
يتم اغلاقها دون ملاحقه او محاسبه ونحن
نقوم بحفظ هذه المعلومات
ومحاوله بناء ملفات للمستوى الدولي على
امل ان يكون هناك انصاف يوما ما للاسرى
الحقل بالتقادم محكمه الجنايات
في هذا العالم
تبقي معنا تحول السيده سوسن مره اخرى
ونتساءل حقيقه متى اخر مره قبلت فيها مرح
ماذا عن ظروف الزيارات هل يسمح لكم
بزيارتها بشكل منتظم ما الذي تنقله لك عن
ظروفي اسرها وتجربه اخريات معها ايضا في
سجون الاحتلال
احنا طبعا في مدينه القدس تختلف نظام
زياراتنا عن الضفه لان الضفه بحتاجوا
لتصاريح عن طريق الصليب الاحمر ليقدروا
يروحوا يزوروا بناتهم او حتى اولادهم لكن
احنا بنقدر نزور مره بالشهر عن عن طريق
الصليب الاحمر ومره بنطلع كمان على حسابنا
الخاص
فكثير زياره متعبه نفسيا انه بتروحي
بتزوري بنتك بتقضي معظم النهار وبالاخر
على 45 دقيقه ما بتتخيل قديش بكون الوضع
صعب انه انت متشوقه تشوفي بنتك بعد غياب
شهر او اسبوعين من الزياره الاخيره
وبتتركيها وبتروحي على البيت في اخر نظره
دائما دائما بتكون كتير كتير صعبه طبعا ما
راح كونها هلا ممثله الاسيرات اللي هي
معناتها متحدثه باسم الاسيرات مع الاداره
اللي بتنقل كل متطلبات الاسيرات اللي
تنقلها لاداره السجون فهذا عمل حمل كبير
على مراحل
الفلسطينيه حتى وهي في القصر يعني لا
تتوقف ابدا عن النضال
اكيد طبعا احنا كتير فخورين بمرح بصغر
سنها اللي هي باعتبارها لاصغر ممثله
اسيرات اللي صار عمرها 24 سنه تحملت
مسؤوليه الاسيرات اللي طبعا عددهم دائما
بكون متفاوت ما في احصائيات ثابته عددهم
31 اسيره صحيح في طفل عندهم قاصر في ست
امهات في جده اللي هي عطاف جرادات في اربع
اسيرات بمدينه القدس اللي هم هلا حبس
منزلي في يعني دائما القدس هي حصه الاسد
موجود في مدينه القدس 15 اسيره من ضمنهم
طبعا الامهات فدائما كل حكينا مع مرح بكون
على وضعهم البنات بشكل عام انا ما بروح
ازور بس مشان اطمن على مرح انا بيهمني
كمان اطمن على اسراء اللي معتصم بيكون
معنا خلال الطريق معتصم اللي كبر معنا
اللي كبر قدامنا زي كمان اولاد اماني
الحشيم برضه كمان فاحنا هون بنصير بطل انه
احنا بس بمجرد ما نروح بنزوره وبنروح لا
احنا صرنا عائلات عشنا مع بعض كثير ظروف
سيئه تعب الزيارات بقعد بناتنا عنا ولكن
لما نشوفهم انهم هم هالقد عازمتهم قويه
بكل الظروف اللي بيمروا فيها شامخات طبعا
مع الاهمال الطبي المتعمد لمعظم الاسيرات
على راسهم طبعا اسرائيل
مرح لاخر موعد للدكتور اللي صار السنه
الماضيه
اقر الدكتور انها مرح بحاجه لعمليه لانعاش
الاعصاب عندها لانه هلا ما راح في طريقي
طلع في الاعصاب عندها لانه بعد سبع سنين
ونص ما راح ما تلقت العلاج اللازم فالفتره
الباقيه لمرح للاسف مش لصالحها بالمره
ولكن اداره السجون للاسف منعت العلاج
وقالت مخبرتها انه هي مش بحاجه للعلاج
وهذا طبعا من سياسه الاهمال الطبي المتعمد
داخل السجون الاسرائيليه كلياتها فاحنا
بنتامل انه ان شاء الله لما ما راح تروح
بالسلامه نعمل لها عمليه بشكل سريع حتى
ننقذ ايدها من لا سمح الله الشلل فهذا
الاشي طبعا باثر علينا كثير نفسيا انه
خلال السبع سنين ونصف ما راح دائما عندها
الاوجاع صيف وشتاء الرطوبه البحر كثير
كثير بتاثر عليها مع كل هذا مرح دائما من
الصبايا اللي ما بتشكيه دائما بتقول الحمد
لله رب العالمين انا منيحه لكن الاس لما
يطلعوا من السجن وبيتم التواصل معهم
بخبروني قديش ما راح بتحسي بوجع بايدها بس
هي دائما من الصبايا اللي بتكابر واللي
دائما بتحب الاداره تشوفها شامخه قويه من
مره ما بتحب تشوفها ضعيفه طبعا كل التحيه
لمرحله كل التحيه ايضا تتحدثين عن النظره
الاخيره عندما تذهبين للزياره ما راح
تابعنا تلك الصور والحضن الكبير الذي قامت
به السيده خالده جرار ولها كل التحيه
لابنتها سها التي فقدتها وهي قيد الاصر كل
محبه وكل التقدير لكل نساء فلسطين اعود
للسيد احمد جرادات سيد احمد يعني ماذا
عنكم هل تمكنتم من زياره عطاف تم ذلك ما
الذي تحكون فيه هل تتحدثون عن ابنائكم
الاسرى ما نوع النقاش او الحوار ان صح لكم
ذلك الذي يكون خلال ربما هذه الوقت اليسير
الذي تتاح فيه الزياره
يعني احنا نعاني كثيرا بالنسبه للزيارات
انا وبعض اولادي لم نتمكن من زياره ابناء
الثلاثه انا ما زرتش ولا واحد الثلاثه منذ
اعتقالهم سنه واربع شهور واما المنتصر
الاخت زوجتي
زرت اربع مرات منعوا هنادي زيارتها بالمره
ولا تحضر محاكم لا هي واخوتها بتحضرش يعني
لا لا اخوتها ولا زيارات واسد منع كذلك
الامر والان لا يجد احد منا مع تصريح حتى
زوجه عمر كانت متزوجه اربع شهور لها اكثر
من شهرين خالص تصريحه ولم يعطوها تصريح
وجده تصريح لا نزور ولا احد جميع اولادي
والثلاثه وزوجتي لا احد يزورهم لا زوجاتهم
ولا انا ولا بناتي ولا قسم من اولادي اللي
خارج السجن
يعني كان الله في العون الاعلاني اعود
بسؤال الاخير لان وقتنا الشرف على
الانتهاء للسيده سحر يعني اكيد هموم نفسيه
ايضا للاسيرات المحررات يخرجن بها يحملنها
اثقالا تضاف الى الاثقال التي عانينها
خلال الاسر السؤال هل يتم التكفل بهم هل
من برامج ربما
لمساعدتهن بعد الخروج من الاسد الذي يكون
تجربه قاسيه جدا مع العزل الانفرادي
الاهمال الطبي الانتهاكات التي تكون قد
عشناها في الاثر
طبعا هناك بعض المؤسسات المحليه التي توفر
المساعدات النفسيه والاجتماعيه
وتحتضن الاسيرات خاصه بعد اطلاق سراح ولكن
هذه التجربه هي تجربه قاسيه جدا فلا اعتقد
ان حتى المسانده النفسيه لها ان تمحو اثار
مثل هذه التجربه عمليا الاسيرات
يتعرضن لتجربه هي اكثر واشد قسوه برايي من
التجربه التي يتعرض لها الرجال خلال عمليه
الاسر وطبعا الاطفال
تجربتهم هي تجربه قاسيه جدا كما الاسيرات
ولكن اعتقد انه الموضوع الجماعي ان
الاسيرات يشعرنا لا يشعرنا بالوحده بعد
الاسر واحتضان العائلات ومسانده العائلات
الحميمه للاسيرات تساعد الاسيرات ايضا على
تجاوز هذه الصعوبات
طبعا قبل ان اشكر ضيفاتي لعل اسرائيل طبعا
هي خارج نطاق القانون الدولي والمساءله
الدوليه تبقى قضيه الاسيرات الفلسطينيات
ربما رهن محاكم الضمير العالمي الذي نزل
حيا ربما لدى البعض اشكره في ختام هذه
الحلقه ضيوفي من رام الله السيده سحر
فرنسيس مديره مؤسسه الضمير لرعايه الاسير
وحقوق الانسان كما اشكر جزيل الشكر من
القدس الشرقيه سوسن بكير والاسيرا مرح
بكير واشكر جزيل الشكر من بلده اسيل
الحارثيه غرب مدينه جنين احمد جرادات زوج
الاسيره ام الاسرى عطاف جردات لان نلتقي
باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه جديده دمتم في
رعايه الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]